[Música]
mi nombre es hugo candelario gonzález si
guapileño de guapi
los primeros pobladores en los indios
huapi es por eso se llama así huapi esa
población mi población mi pueblo y mi
terruño
esta conferencia está charla más bien
no tiene intenciones ni pretensiones
científicas ni técnicas más bien la
intención reflexiva
se titula destino
identidad y libertad a través de la
música
en la película forrest gump hay un
momento en que tomamos el actor está
haciendo una reflexión de su vida como
él a pesar de consciente de sus
limitaciones
valora y reconoce todo lo que su madre
todo lo que la fortaleza la enseñanza el
amor propio la autoestima que le inyectó
para poder sortear las dificultades y
todas las vicisitudes de la vida pero
llegar a un punto en que bueno ya
también era el destino muchas cosas
dependían directamente de él o de esa
enseñanza o de ese aprendizaje pero
llegaba un punto que era cesárea es su
comprensión porque era el destino
en mi caso es al revés un poco porque
comienza por el destino
que yo me llamo hugo candelario porque
cuando nazca mi mi pueblo mi población
está en ningún incendio grandísimo
se quemó todo el pueblo prácticamente
pero nazca en un incendio por eso
me pusieron candelario me imagino que si
hubiera nacido en diciembre me han
puesto un alguacil o
algo por el estilo pero
era el destino es eso para mí
nacer precisamente en esas
circunstancias recibir toda esa ansiedad
dificultad recibir de mi madre porque ya
tenía 88 hijos adelante de su esposo en
la casa están varios abuelos mi mamá fue
una matrona es una matrona porque vive
todavía mi vida
y ha cuidado a todo el mundo además de
su familia creó el ancianato en guapi y
es madrina de medio pueblo bueno desde
ellas son mi papá idiomas son barbacoa
nos comerciantes y se trasladaron agua
barbacana barbacoas nariño
entonces para mí eso es el destino
destino es también que como el pueblo
estaba en incendio en una quema
grandísima
tuvieron que llamar a alguien que iba
manejando una lancha una canoa porque no
había por dónde ir por las calles no
había por dónde llegar al hospital
coincidencialmente la persona que iba
manejando el motorista de la lancha era
mi maestro gualajo jose antonio torres
que desafortunadamente se nos fue hace
34 meses cosa del destino
coincidencialmente del destino el día
que murió yo estaba en guapi en la casa
de él con sus hermanos
los maestros torres que son como una
dinastía de el folclor del pacífico
colombiana en la parte de guapi don
genaro torres del mayor y pacho torres
el menor constructores herederos de toda
esa
de todo ese bagaje ancestral de la
música del pacífico
destino nacer en esa familia numerosa
bonita recibir todo s
toda esa enseñanza
identidad porque ahí se fue formando ahí
se fue formando de ese primer inicio
desde de esa primera circunstancia de
nacimiento destino estar allí en la que
mis padres tenían un almacén vendían
marimbas vendían un 1 bombo no eran los
constructores ellos les compraban a los
torres a los a los diferentes luthier de
las de la región artesanías bueno era un
almacén de diferentes productos entre
ellos los instrumentos y la artesanía yo
chiquitico pequeñito me tocó estar allí
por cosas del destino viendo cuando un
marín ver un maestro un constructor
llegaba a dejar su marimba en mi casa la
registraba
yo estaba ahí me tocaba estar ahí
circunstancial cosas del destino ese fue
mi primer contacto porque no en la
familia no hay músicos no tengo un
referente familiar musical como para
sentir que fue por allí hay buen oído
como todo en el pacifico tenemos buen
oído todos tenemos buen ritmo
en guapi todo el mundo compone todo el
mundo baila actúa eso es una
es un
ramillete de talento natural silvestre
se da por ahí
todo el mundo tiene alguna
característica artística
entonces
ahí se fue generando mi identidad
regreso a guapi
y ahí tengo la oportunidad de cantar más
en el terreno de tocar la música un poco
más popular yo tocaba la flauta la
marimba un poco
después llegó acá bueno esta ciudad me
enamoró desde muy pequeñito a muy
temprana edad una vez mis padres me
trajeron desde que desde que me bajé del
avión me gustó el olor es el olor no lo
olvido es un olor para como nuevo solo
como nuevo que no lo olvido desde ahí
quedé enamorado de cali y en esta ciudad
en esta ciudad tengo que vivir algún día
no pude sino hasta s hasta en el año 85
porque el calendario del pacífico y
bogotá era a jackie árabe nunca nunca
pude cuadrara y ese ese semestre de
diferencia te llegue a cali por fin por
fin me sale aquí y me viene con una
marimba viene con una marimba
tradicional construida por don silvino
mina que aún está vivo es un luthier
marimbero de los grandes maestros de la
tradición en guapi
pero entonces cuando iba a tratar de
relacionarme con los otros músicos ya
aquí a cali no podía entrar con mi
marido porque ella venía con su
afinación tradicional la afinación de la
marimba tradicional es una maquinación
propia autóctona vernácula para tocar
música del pacífico como no hay
instrumentos armónicos que la acompañen
no sé y las voces se acomodan a esa
afinación tradicionalmente hablando
yo no sabía esos códigos mucho entonces
vi que no podía entrar me tocó hacer el
proceso de temperar la afinar la hacia
el 440 para poder tocar con los demás
músicos aquí en cali bueno ahí me fui
desarrollado entre el conservatorio ta
ta ta ta ta
fui desarrollando mi carrera musical
por cosas del destino llegó a timbiquí
en el último festival del currulao que
se hizo un año 1987 88 yo ya estaba
estudiando en el conservatorio fui hace
con una investigación
hay una canción que se llama por ahí la
memoria de justino
[Música]
y
como tocaban cómo se oía como repiten
esa marimba estilo garcía ese señor
salió en protesta porque no lo dijeron
no lo dejaron concursar ahí en el pueblo
en timbiquí no dejaron concursar esa vez
había otro grande maestro pero él no
pudo él era un viejito así vas y pico
con la carita medio reñida y decían que
tenía pacto con el duende porque tocaba
muchísimo tocaba rápidos ya tocaba con
32 tacos en la mano izquierda y uno en
la derecha era rarísimo para pues para
la tradición es existe esa técnica es
tradición entonces el domingo
el domingo después del festival
el protesta él salió
y
y que empezó a tocar allí en la cancha
del pueblo de timbiquí de santa barbara
steele y kirk y porque se les indique es
el río y varios municipios pertenecen al
río timbiquí entre ellos la cabecera la
capital que santa bárbara de timbiquí
entonces empiezo a tocar
y ese señor era un pintor un poeta de la
marimba
empezó a tocar a recorrer a pintar en
ese instrumento
y fue suficiente verlo una vez en la
vida para que me influenciará tanto la
sencilla como músico y la forma de tocar
la marimba
cosas del destino ya formó bahía
año 1997
se está programando ya el petronio
primer festival primera versión del
festival de música del pacífico petronio
álvarez 1997 el grupo bahía tiene una
invitación para ir a inglaterra estamos
tramitando las visas por un papel que no
llegó a tiempo
no pudimos viajar no nos dieron la visa
es la brújula se fue hacia el petróleo
nos empezamos a preparar para el
petróleo bueno para no alargar el cuento
ganamos el petróleo con bombo y
platillo' trata muchos premios una nueva
una nueva puerta se abrió
para la bahía para la música del
pacífico y para mucho para todo este
proceso que está sucediendo en este
momento bueno pero volviendo un poquito
atrás a la parte de timbiquí en esa
oportunidad veía qué
si por el día sonaba el folklore sonaba
todo pero en las noches en la discoteca
en las casas no sonaba la música del
pacífico no estaba grabada la marimba no
estaba grabada está sesionando diez años
antes del petronio 87 y hasta el 1997
que ganamos el primer petróleo que
tuvimos la oportunidad por ese premio
dejar de grabar se pudo grabarlo la
marimba ahí tuvimos la oportunidad de
grabar la isie y empezó una nueva era
también de la música el pacífico porque
previamente pues ya había estado ya
sabemos el maestro perego yo el maestro
alexis lozano bueno muchos maestros que
ya estaban naciendo
todo su aporte con la música para
resumir vienen unas claves unas matrices
esa que le dije viene otra que llega
directamente a cuba de áfrica
en el caribe básicamente arrasan al
indígena a la herencia indígena
básicamente se acaba obviamente en el
continente no esa misma clave es avión
matriz llega al continente pero como en
el continente si está en el continente
si está el indígena y el indígena tiene
su sentido rítmico
viene y se junta con esa
tierra no viene directamente de áfrica
fresquitas a esa matriz tan tan
es acá en el continente se puede volver
tranquilamente
[Música]
e
yo no tengo la investigación científica
para ni mú psicológica ni antropológica
para poder explicar eso que estoy
transmitiendo en este momento pero si lo
siento y si sé si sé que es así que esa
misma clave es esa misma clave s
se juntó con lo indígena aquí y se fue
volviendo esa matriz para mí
y el caribe los caribeños son como
hermanos mayores
o sea la mamá es
la gran la tierra y la gran dama la
matrona y está áfrica de áfrica viene
todo ese ese bagaje rítmico es una
familia
ahí se vuelven hogares cubas tobin white
y jamaica
jamaica es una es una familia es una
familia y son peces son unos hermanos
mayores son dos hermanos mayores que nos
han influenciado con su música hemos
heredado hemos bailado es el tambor que
están dando
pero iba llegando hasta el continente y
lo vamos aceptando pero yo siento que
como el hermano menor también me
corresponde sacar y contar mi propia
historia
ellos como caribeños como hermanos han
contado como hermanos mayores han
contado ya su historia
nosotros como oriundos del pacífico'
oriundo de esta región también tenemos
nuestra propia matriz también tenemos
nuestra propia clave tenemos esa
herencia como hermanos mayores pero
tenemos que contar también nuestra
propia historia tenemos muchas cosas por
que sentirnos orgullosos y les podría
contar muchas anécdotas y muchos
ejemplos de porque me siento lleno de
identidad sobre todo lleno de amor
propio por lo nuestro por donde nací y
por lo que he heredado por eso quiero
tanto a mis viejos a mis ancestros
porque por eso defiendo tanto la música
del pacifico y si quiero hacer una
invitación por ejemplo a los músicos a
los músicos de esta región
que contemos nuestra propia historia la
idea no es rechazar nada de lo que ya
tenemos aprendido ni pelear con nada
porque eso es esa ancestralidad heredada
riquísima en el pacífico nos criamos
todos bailando salsa son todo esto ritmo
pero creo así como muchos compañeros de
esta noche ha ido contando y han
utilizado una palabra como algo nuevo
reinventarse el azar lo imprevisto la
improvisación no sacamos la oportunidad
de algo nuevo de pintar la página en
blanco
de decir nuevamente de volvernos a
contar nuestra historia de reconocernos
valorar nos auto querernos más porque
tenemos con que tenemos
por eso yo puedo pararme igual ha ido
por todo el mundo
falta australia
yo me reúno con un africano o con un
japonés con un griego este soy yo esta
es mi identidad esa identidad me da
libertad esa identidad me da una
sensación de que puedo viajar sin temor
por el mundo me siento libre y así como
me críe libre en guapi muchas gracias
[Música]
destino identidad y libertad
muchas gracias por la oportunidad
[Aplausos]